Alright. Hello and welcome everyone to
ActInf Lab Livestream number 38 Dot One.
It's February 16,
2022. Welcome to ActInf
Lab. We are a participatory online lab
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links on this
slide. This is a recorded and an
archived livestream, so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome and we'll be
following video etiquette for live
stream. Just release an unending torrent
of emojis if you have to speak or just
raise your hand. I'm sure that will get
to it. If you're watching Live, please
feel free to write questions in the live
chat and we'll have enough time to hang
out and discuss during this dot one
where we'll be opening into the paper.
Check ActiveInference.org for
updated information on participating in
any of the labs activities. I hope
you'll find something that resonates
with you today in ActInf
Livestream number 38 Dot One. We're going to
be learning and discussing this cool
paper "The Evolution of Brain
Architectures for Predictive Coding and
Active Inference" by Pazulo, Parr, and
Friston from December 2021.
And we're just going to enjoy
discussing it and opening up any idea or
questions that us here on the panel
have, or those who are live chatting us.
And we have some ideas and thoughts,
prepared a few things that we know that
we can go into. And also I hope that
everyone has brought some other prepared
seeds and also, of course,
spontaneously feeling like new
things are arising. So we'll just start
with some introduction and warmup. We
can each say hi and then maybe it'd be
cool to just also mention like, what got
you excited about the paper or what
image you want to discuss this paper,
what's something that stayed with you?
So I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California and I was very excited by the
evolutionary focus. A lot of my research
over the last years has been in
evolution and ecology, so it's always
awesome to see how people are thinking
about how active inference, free energy
principle and evolutionary studies can
all be learning from one another. And
I'll klaas. E. Stephan.
Hello, I'm Steven Silly. I'm in Toronto.
I'm really interested in how this paper
connects to my work with spatial meaning
making and social topographies because
this paper talks about more biological
nascent stage of development rather than
some higher order meaning that often
people think about. And I'm really
interested in how this sort of grounded
bottom up and active ecological
approaches can be thought about as
something where we can actually ground a
lot of our learning making. So I'm
inference in how this might match with
some of that thinking and I will pass
this over to Dean. Thanks,
Dean. I'm Dean, I'm in Calgary. What I
found interesting about the paper is
that given that I've worked with a lot
of young learners for a lot of my life.
It was really interesting to see how
this affirmed a lot of the thinking that
I was doing when I was trying to get
people past the idea that science is
only about the biology and the chemistry
and the physics that there is a
statistical and predictive component to
this. And those relationships in that
realm can build certain sense of
what the underlying architectures is.
So, as I said, a lot of this is
affirmations and it's kind of seen as
being not part of what it's typically
address core learning. But I think it
should be back to you, Dan. Cool.
Nice intro. Let's just start with a big
question and then either of you have any
reflections on the big question? Or
we'll go over to Blank Slide and just
bring up some questions we have. And
also it might be good to go over just
some of the key points in the paper,
like what did they actually do in terms
of their contribution? So the big
question, or at least one way to phrase
something that might bring someone to
approach this paper what is the
evolutionary neurophysiological basis of
cognition and how do complex cognitive
phenotypes arise? Like, you don't go
from zero to colony in one time step.
How does it happen that evolution arises
from precursor, sometimes simpler, but
also sometimes more complicated
precursors? Stephen mentioned what
is the basis for sense making? And
cognition and sense making are very
related. And what's been fun over these
last weeks and months is we've explore
basic or simple or reduced or basal
cognition from a variety of
perspectives. Like, we talked about the
bioelectric components of thinking
about basal cognition with Mike Levin.
Now we're thinking about a slightly
different approach to understanding
basal cognition niche we'll be
discussing here. And then also we've
looked at some of these more complex
cognitive phenotypes like mental action,
counterfactuals, deep temporal
inference, all the active logic
which we'll get into probably later.
How can we use generative models of
perception, cognition, action, and
impact like active inference to study
this whole continuum and diversity of
relatively simpler in our perspective
cognition, and also relatively more
complex cognitive phenotypes and
everything in between? So Klaas.
Stephan and then on with it. Thanks,
Daniel. Yeah, I mean, I suppose also
what some of the paradigm impacts of
that, of taking that all the way through
one question that might come up which
you may or may not have an answer to or
thoughts on. But Mike Levin's
work with the ecological cones at
the different nested levels and how this
sort of could be thinking about what
kind of action control
potential these different nested
levels might exist. I would be
interested to think about how this may
either be able to connect to that I can
see it connecting philosophically or
whether there's another bridge needed
between this modeling and that type of
modeling. Just something I mentioned.
Great.
Dean anything to add or perhaps I'm.
Going to wait till you get to figure
one. Okay,
so we won't go through all of
the Kilner points in the paper. That's
for the reading of the paper itself.
Nor will we even go over all of the
overview, which is what the dot zero
video 38.0 is for. So turn back time
and watch that one if you haven't, or
pause the video if you're not watching
it live. But what this paper does,
as evidenced by the Roadmap,
is introduce a few basic principles of
cognition, predictive regulation and
control and then also structure learning
in generative model models. That's not
how every neurophysiology text is going
to begin the building blocks of
cognition. It's not how every
evolutionary neurophysiology text is
going to be framing cognition, but
that's what they do here and that will
play into how it's similar and different
than other approaches. Then with those
building blocks in hand or on the floor,
they provide three examples of motifs
that ancestral brains may be
modeled as having or may have actually
had. With those three examples in
hand, it's then possible for them to
state a more general way of thinking
about the transitions amongst different
structures. These structures represent
brain design as structured learning and
generative models. That is called an
evolutionary algebra. And they introduce
five operators that can basically either
leave unchanged or change the
structure of brain design with respect
to generative Model models. And each of
those are explored in terms of what are
brain architectures changes that that
evolutionary transition is and
then what are the functional
consequences of that kind of an
evolutionary transition. Then they have
some discussions about how sequences or
patterns of application of this
evolutionary algebra could lead to
different evolutionary phenomena. So for
example, increasing temporal depth in
the future means that models are
increasingly prospective. Increasing
temporal depth in the past is like
memory, etc. And then they close with
mapping to a phylogenetic tree and
thinking about that evolutionary algebra
of state transitions being mapped onto
the bifurcating tree structure that's
called a phylogenetic tree which shows
the relatedness of different life forms.
That's the roadmap. Let's go to the long
awaited figure one and talk about
the action perception cycle and
predictive evolution. And so they're
gain discussing this in the context of
predictive regulation, anticipatory
regulation, cybernetics and control as
a basic design principle for the brain.
So Dean, what do you see here or what
would be cool to think about?
So one of this follows I think is the
usual pattern when we're trying to
explain where we're going to go. And so
you just had a roadmap up and I think a
roadmap is a way for the people who are
reading the Roadmap to find their way.
But I think what this diagram shows is
that in the middle of there, there's
something called a discrepancy. And that
discrepancy is later going to be given a
label y. And what
I think is really interesting here is
there's a flip potentially that can
happen here. That discrepancy is where
what I would describe as a rule factory
and rule in the sense that we find
patterns that's kind of our place where,
as it says, the prediction and the
observation come together. And I
belief that that's different than a
roadmap, which is find your way. I
believe that discrepancy or that road
factory is wayfinding. And I think what
we have the potential to do with this
paper because of the way that they have
sort of presented the information is the
words become eventually become
explicated rules, which then become
action in the phenomenological space.
That's where it gets really, really
interesting because I think most of the
time when people look at things as a
subject, they've taken the world and
they've collapsed down to words and
diagrams and models. What this
potentially allows us to do is flip that
and move from the words back out into
the space with a little bit more
confidence. So, yeah, that's why I
wanted to kind of start here because I
think the word discrepancy, it's the
first time I've seen it in this kind of
figure model and I really like it.
Cool. Yeah. It makes me think about
setting off on the road trip on the
mental actions that reflect the paper.
And there's the roadmap, which is super
informative, but it is like
instructionalism. It's saying you're
going to go two streets and then take a
left turn at the stop sign. And then
when this happens, then you'll do that.
And if you've seen this, then you've
gone too far. Kind of classic
instruction type sequences.
Here we have a figuring out because
it's visually arranged with some local
connectivity that's suggestive of a
causal connection through time. But by
no means is there only one way to read
this simultaneous figure. And so that
allows potentially for more of a
figuring out, including the figuring out
of rules. Yes, it is indeed a
little different with discrepancy at the
intersection here. Stephen. Yeah, so
this ties in with the lower bound
evidence control approach
of action. So the idea is that
action is what we can tractably
approximate and perception
is something that we can
access but can't, and we can try to make
more sense of, but it is a
harder piece of the equation to
get a handle on. So I'm wondering if
that's how do you feel about that
exploration in terms of its use across
other areas of applied active inference?
So I think it could make things a little
bit more digestible for a
number of concepts.
Okay. I'm thinking about this in the
context of recognizing that it's
different than other action perception
loops that we've seen, which is just
really important to keep in mind that
we're not perceiving something that
we're projecting too much because other
times the outgoing arrow from the entity
is. What if this were a Markov blanket
type diagram, which they often are, the
outgoing arrow would reflect active
states and then the statistical
dependencies that are outgoing. But
where is action? It's on the bottom
right. So let's really try
to understand why the pieces are placed
this way. The outgoing feature of the
cognitive entity is the prediction and
here's observation coming in. If this
were a Markov blanket diagram, we'd have
the world and then the incoming
statistical arrow would be the
observation, that would be the sensory
states. So here it's
the outgoing prediction of the entity
and the incoming sensory data or
observation. Those two are being
differentiate to form a discrepancy,
which is just a qualitative term, but it
could be then brought a little bit more
formally into a prediction errors or
a little bit even beyond that into like
a free energy differential. This
discrepancy has two arrows
coming out of it. From the discrepancy
is arising perception and
the changing of beliefs. Does perception
always involve changing beliefs? And
discrepancy is also giving rise to
action. So what kind of a thing is
discrepancy such that the inputs are
prediction and observation and the
outputs are perception and action?
So at the very least this is not the
Bayesian graph representations that
we've seen before or that we'll see in
just a few slides with a more
traditional interpretation of nodes as
random variables and edges as
statistical dependencies. This is a
little bit more like a thought map that
then connects to the variational free
energy equation which we talked about in
number 37 a lot more. But just to
recall, there's the red and the Bleu
lines, these two different components of
the variational free energy and those
are shown again here. So check out 37 to
learn more about the red and the Bleu
and about variational and expected free
energy. But for here we're starting with
this action prediction discrepancy motif
and then connecting it to perception and
action as variational free energy.
Minimization Stephen I think one
thing that's. Useful with this more
nascent representation is this
discrepancy can go into in different
directions. So it can be discrepancy in
terms of temporal occurrence,
when was the prediction predicted to
happen, when was it observed, but it
could also be what kind of prediction
and what kind of observation or
whereabouts was the prediction,
whereabouts was the observation as many
different and at different scales.
So there may be that at
the kind of lower levels. There's quite
a big jump between when I predict
the baseball encoding to my hand,
when that prediction was made, when that
observation occurs, and also
when that is chained up at
different slower, bigger steps of the
nested Markov blanket sort of sequence.
So this idea of discrepancy is I
suppose it's probably the biggest bucket
they could find, I would imagine at that
spot. And that may be partly why it's
there. Can I just add to Klaas.
E. Stephan think one of the things
that's interesting, especially after
just doing the 37 paper where we were
talking about guides, to me, the timing
of this was absolutely immaculate,
because now all of a sudden we've gone
from guiding to almost taking
potentially a referee's position on the
world, which is a whole different thing
than taking up the position of being a
guide. I mean, that's not nuanced,
that's not subtle. That's quite an
identity shift. And we're going to
actually get into identity when we look
at some of the evolutionary steps later
on. But I wanted to slow down on this
because I thought that's not a minor
change, that's a whole different
perspective shift. And I think we need
to really make note of that because I
think it colors a lot of what's to
follow. What makes
you say that we're a referee in this
situation? Discrepancy.
There's a difference between what the
world is telling us and then how we rule
on that. So think of any game where you
get into an argument with the rest.
Are they wrong, are you wrong? It
doesn't really matter. The point is that
there's a difference that's when you
said differential graph is maybe one of
the ways to be able to make that
explicit, but that's not how it's
typically framed out when we're
talking about Bayesian or Markovian
stuff. So I think this is a big move.
I know it might seem like a tiny one,
but I think as we go again, as we go
deeper into this paper, it affirms a lot
of the stuff that I actually saw when
you're trying to go out there and forage
and figure. So I'm excited to keep
going. Yeah, it could be like the
observation. The baseball player is
running towards the base and the coach
is observing and there's this ongoing
prediction and observation with no
discrepancy because part of the
generative model includes the person
moving through time. And then given
the observation and the generative model
the coach predicts, slash, expects and
prefers, which we'll come to again later
with the three piece that the baseball
player is safe. You rarely see super
animated refusals when a call has gone
towards somebody, but it's when it has
gone against, it's violated their
fitness that there's a discrepancy with
what the referee has called and what the
interested coach has called. And that
is going to lead to some consequences.
And again, we're still not at the
Bayesian graph level, but that's going
to be the next figure. Steven.
This can then Bull on
the idea of what's cognitive, what can
you have a perspective on? I think what
you're saying there with this referee
position is as well as the kind of
swarming dynamics and the kind of
inactive processes, much of which is
beyond our ability to sense or
integrate. What is it once it starts to
hit? What's the big bucket at the kind
of cognition level that still isn't too
much of an inflation.
So in this case here, discrepancy.
There is a sense of being able to
distinguish perception and action at
some level and find a discrepancy,
which in some ways I
would imagine covers a lot of what
cognition would require to be thought of
in a cognition way. Other types of
action, for instance, how we heal or
grow, maybe action and
perception won't be so separated. But
this is trying to come at the idea of
cognition. So maybe that also informs
this process. Cool. So action two,
again, was just about the two concepts
of predictive regulation and control.
That's what we saw here, predictive and
control. So it's just conceptually laid
out in figure two.
They formalize brain design as structure
learning in generative models.
So here we have a difference figure.
We still have the
cognitive entity and the world. We add
in one layer of absolutely essential
active terms, which is generative
models, generative process. The
generative model is the cognitive
entity's model of the
generative process is the underlying
phenomena that gives rise to
observations. It's the difference
between the cognitive model of vision,
a generative model of vision, and the
generative process of visual input,
which is like photons and the sun and
all of that. So these are very
different. They're complementary. But
just so that we're really clear going
forward that we're going to be using
those in their specific sense, not using
them like, oh well, it's a generative
model because this is a model of
cognition that makes me excited and
think of ideas, that's not how we're
using generative models here. So just to
be clear on that, now we see
action as changing the world represented
by you. And the cognition involves
partially action selection,
policy selection, planning as inference,
but not going to all those details yet,
which can have some influence on actual
unobserved, hidden states of the world.
X star. X is the cognition
model of that hidden state of the world
that is being inferred.
And Y is the observation that then feeds
back into the cognitive model.
So that's what these nodes mean.
It's about partitioning the cognitive
model from the generative process,
separating the generative models from
the generative process. And we're
starting to see the traditional blanket
form with observations having incoming
statistical dependencies and actions
having outgoing statistical
dependencies. What else do either of you
see in this model?
Yahtin.
So let's go back to being a referee
for a second. The assumptions is that
you're already attending. And most of
these models that we have taken up
in the past, especially in 37,
what they try to focus on is getting
from A to B. What this is essentially
saying is let's add something to that
translation right from A to B. Whatever
we're trying to incorporate in this
representation, let's maybe look at the
interpretation part of it now and the
recitation part of it. So if I'm the
umpire and we can all be umpires. We
don't have to do that just in a baseball
game. This is incorporating now a
certain critical process. I was
attention and I saw this, but then there
were 600 other people also paying
attention and they saw that. That's
where I think this is getting really
interesting. Now this is actually
bringing it back to sort of I still
think it's an instrumental piece, but I
think now we're going to incorporate
some of the reality. Were the 600 wrong
or is the one person who yelled out safe
wrong? That's what I see in this
because that you is definitely embedded
in the generative process, not the
generative models.
Okay. Thanks, Dean Steven.
So the question that comes into
mind is where the body is
in all of this. And I sense that
the generative process is the bigger
process with the world. The generative
model gives away
to access those prior
and to give away the hidden states.
And the cognitive model, generally
speaking, cognition is thought of more
in terms of deductive and inductive
reasoning and logic. And it
could be that there's elements of
the abductive that could be held within
the kind of body. And I suppose there's
a question there as to how
and where that is. I don't think anyone
quite knows the answer to that, but
that's my thought. So let's
remember that this partitioning is
specific to a given instantiation of
model based science, just like Majid was
talking about. So we're not going around
and assigning aspects or phenomena of
the world into either a generative model
or generative process. So where does the
body fit in? Well, with respect to a
model of the body being a structurally
real thing that gives rise to
observations, it's a generative process
looking at the coin from the other side
and thinking of the body as a generative
model of its niche, doing inference on
certain things or acting as if in that
sense it's generative models. So
different kinds of entities are not
going to be just assigned simply to one
side or the other. It's going to come
down to what is specifically being
discussed. There's a few
other not complexifiers, but first off,
just note that the notation here is not
the same that's used elsewhere. So we
will move towards better and cleaner or
reformattable notation. But like X star
as an external state and X as an
internal state might be clearer for some
people. It also carries a little bit of
a baggage that the hidden states is
exactly what is being inferred about the
entorhinal world. Like there's a
temperature parameter in the brain and
then there's a temperature parameter
outside in the world as we explore in
the representations paper. It doesn't
necessarily have to be that way. There
could be a hidden states internally
having to do with movements left to or
right and then there's a temperature
variable outside and then the model,
the generative model of the Cognizer is
about movement conditioned on
temperature observations, but not
necessarily simply a thermometer
being instantiated in the head. So it's
like good to look at this graphically
and think about what is being connected
to what without worrying too much
about all of these side questions. But
this is what they're setting up as the
basis of their further dimension, which
is it's about prediction and control and
we can use Bayesian graphical approaches
to represent that. Steven.
And that influence state, as you
mentioned, in some ways that's always
slightly hidden from us. What does that
Dean to be an inferred state in terms
of? Is that the cognition that's coming
out of that in some sort of deductive or
can it be an effective sense of how well
something is going? So again, it's not
directly asked here, but accessing
that is one of the big problems that
happens. How do you access what has been
inferred when it's not necessarily
something you can access through sort of
direct reporting from a subject matter,
from a participant? Right? Like another
example of that might be somebody who
has skilled action with respect to
investing, but they may not be able to
give an estimate for a number that's a
certain asset is expected to be at
because it's not like they're doing the
asset price prediction and then doing a
strategy. The cognition model may have a
very different structure, so we explored
it in the representation in this paper.
But like there would be ways in which
therefore that investment decision is
not a representation of the actual stock
market because it's not the same
variable. But then the aboutness of the
investment decision would be a
representation with respect to what was
happening in the generative process. So
those were some of the side avenues that
we've looked at previously, but they're
all in play at once. And so the question
is just how to linearly structure to
respect the specific contributions that
are made here and the insight that can
be gleaned without every single time
pulling back to some of these questions.
But it's great that we have like
specific papers and memes and core terms
that we can refer to and
then carry on with what they actually
contribute. Okay, any thoughts on
one or two before we get into the
structure of the Alo stat
or the homeostat first, I guess.
Let's go. Okay, so we're going to go
from this black and white Dorothy still
in Kansas mode to
some predictive motifs of ancestral
brains. And the three motifs, the red,
green and Bleu are homeostasis.
So returning to a set point, allostasis
anticipating or approaching a set point
in the future, which could be a fixed or
changing one and then implementing
behavior control, not just scalar
homeostasis or allostasis on an
interceptive variable.
Okay, citation 20 in
the paper chance at all from the future.
March 22 is where to look for
more details on the homeostatic
formulation that they're using here but
we can see it in terms of their figure
free. Okay, so the left side just for
reference there's figure two so that we
can remember the structure of
perception, cognition, action, impact
that the authors are working with here.
And we're going to connect this black
and white figure two to figure three
A. This is a graphical model,
graphical in both senses, meaning
visual, like we're perceiving it through
computer graphics and graphical meaning
like a network so nodes and edges
because there's computer graph that
aren't network topologies. But this
happens to be a computer graphic that
we're perceiving visually that also is
reflecting a graph in terms of nodes and
connected edges. It's a generative
models for the regulation of
a single interceptive variable. So
here's A and B with the homeostat and C
we split out to talk about later. But
first A and B. This generative models
includes an interoceptive thermoreceptor
and a belief about body temperature.
The prior over X, which is body
temperature, is kept fixed and hence it
acts as a cybernetic set point. Any
discrepancy between the predictive,
thermoreceptor activity given beliefs
about X. So Y conditioned on X and the
measured y is registered as a prediction
error that is canceled out by an
autonomic response. U, for example, a
thermoregulatory response. So hidden
states on temperature, beliefs about
temperature, why the thermometer
perception and then there's the
selection of action. So some sort of
like vasodilation or thermoregulatory
response and then that's going to change
the underlying unobserved true
temperature but that's not needing to be
shown. So any comments on that first
part? We're looking just at the top half
of three A and connecting XY
to you. Action.
Can you still hear me? Yes.
Can you take the cursor now and just
reinforce the feedback and the feed
forward part of this because the author
spent a bit I don't want it sort of
unpacked like they have at the figure
three unpacking that we have at the
bottom of the slide. Can you just run
the cursor over all the examples of
feedback and feed forward going on
concurrently? Because I think that's
really important to see that it's
happening in both directions at once.
Let's label everything and then
definitely can do that. Perfect. Thank
you.
Okay, so light Bleu is
action. These are
subtracted. So red circles represent
expected values of
X. The red circles which
are used to make predictions about Y,
these are subtracted to form a
prediction error.
Because those lines with the arrows on
the end of them are just dependencies.
They don't really show both the feedback
and the feed forward.
Yes, agreed. Like having some rounded
edges and other directed
edges. Let's see whether it's whether
they're like kind or not.
Let's start with action. Action
influences the state of the world which
an edge can be drawn to, how that
changes the state of. The thermo
receptor. Why? Here was the
observation. Yeah. That's the state of
the thermoreceptor is the observation.
Okay. Yeah. So action changes this the
observation, the state of the thermo
receptor which
is being contrasted with
the belief about temperature. From
there, a prediction error is generated.
It could be zero if there's no
difference, or it could be higher.
Can you just show, with some colored
line that has an arrow on each end a
connection that demonstrates within that
diagram the feedback and the feed
forward at once? Is that possible
using this diagram? Let's see it's
representation. So a single arrow, a
single line that has an Aaron Fath.
Both ends is a different color. So we've
superimposed it over this, but that it
shows that there's a feedback feed
forward loop going off at the same time.
Okay. So here's the temperature
information measurement flowing in to
contrast with the beliefs. And it is
in general, really important to label
the edges, not just use color coding.
We'll let it roll for now. The
information is flowing from the
measurements to the belief and then that
gives us the prediction error.
Then the prediction error is used
in the selection of action,
which then influences future
observations.
Now the red circles represent expected
values of x.
I'm actually not sure what exactly the
red bottom, larger circle is meaning.
Because the prediction error well,
there has. To be some way of
representing that discrepancy. Right?
So they needed the second ball on
the bottom to show difference between
prediction errors and expectation. I
think that's all that's trying to show.
Yeah. Or another possibility might be
that the prior is staying field.
Correct.
They can be flexible, but in this case
it's a fixed prior. That's because we're
talking about homeostasis. Then the
observations are diverging from the
prior and the posterior is
kind of like the realized perception,
which is a compromise between the
sensory data coming in and the prior.
And so, yes, there's a lot of degrees of
freedom depending on how parameters are
weighted. This green line might
approximate the red a lot more sharply.
We call that a weaker prior because
sensory data updates the posterior to be
more like it. Or it
could be the case that having a lot of
observations different from your prior
don't change it. That's a strong prior
where sensory data do not change it as
much. But then here is the prediction
error in relationship
to x. I don't know. We can look at the
paper, but is Mu shown
in an equation? I don't have it copied
out if it is. Let me look here while
you're doing that. Yeah, but that is the
perhaps here. Okay.
Steven, anything?
Yeah, I'm just noticing how effective
the belief on temperature.
It flows through the thermoset
down into the to get the expectation
prediction error. So,
like you've shown there, there is a
dynamic going down from the belief
through to prediction error being
mediated. It's like the thermoceptor is
kind of like a mediator between belief
and prediction error on
what to do for action.
And another point, the reason why you
can't find the mu is because it's not
actually pointed to in the description.
It's not really true. Yeah, and I
remember reading and looking and looking
and looking and not being able to find
it and then looping back up paper to go,
okay, so how about feedback feed
forward. Now, there are cases
where view is used to describe internal
states that
may be implicitly how it's being used,
but it's super important that all
variables are defined in a paper. I wish
they all had a table for every single
variable and expression that were used.
Yeah, it would make the dot zeros
easier, but also it would reduce
uncertainty.
For example, is this epsilon even
described? Okay. Steven. I mean, I
suppose in a thermostat in some ways the
internal states of the bioelectric
strip in some ways it
holds the way
that the expectation of action
can happen because in some ways it
dictates the way that the
thermostat will behave in some sort of
ways, even if it's kind of an analog
process where
would the kind of Kilner thermostat I
know this is a homeostat, so it's a bit
more sophisticated now. But
extrapolating that out, you've kind of
got a belief, and there's a belief
of what something is, and then there's
an expectation of what you can do about
it. For instance, my beliefs can go
bigger than what I can do in my actions.
I could have beliefs about temperature
which exceeds where I can even exist or
where I am able to change it. It depends
on the scenario. So it's held in
both scenarios in both the body and
the context and the kind of
probabilities available. Okay, so for
a nonliving thermostat,
it doesn't have a cognitive belief on
temperature, but there could be
something that's computationally like
that reflected by just a digital prior
on temperature. And again, these aren't
cognitive, personal, effective,
experienced beliefs. Bayesian belief.
This is just saying random variable
reflecting in a model variable on
temperature. So even a sincerely held
incorrect ecological belief is not the
Bayesian belief. They might coincide at
times if it were a parameter, but the
belief here being the
prior,
it must be adaptive. That's the
evolutionary twist that actually helps
resolve a lot of this because otherwise
the design space of all edges by all
nodes and then any variable I mean,
it's just like saying here's all the
words in the dictionary. And so
evolution helps restrict the discussion
to cases that actually do manage to
achieve adaptive control. Dean this is
where the translation from the
silhouette of a head to a statistical
density is assumed that the person who's
following along with this just sees
that. But you can also see how easy it
is to slip into the idea that,
oh, wait, a second, we've gone from the
physical space and we just held on to
the physical space, when really now
we're talking about a statistical
density space. And again, if you're
not really, really careful, you can see
how people can carry forward something.
But the actual thing that they're
talking about has changed. That's why
the word discrepancy was such a big deal
to me, because I normally gloss over
things, but this time it actually I
went, oh, okay. So there's going to be
some there's going to be some moments
here where we're actually talking about
different things, even though in the
continuum we kind of think that they're
talking about the same thing. No, we're
not. Yes,
it's the travails of Realism and
instrumentalism for Biological Active
Inference episode 55 because of
these terms, are they an examples or is
this an example of a model being used to
discuss a real system? But this
suffice to say, is the architecture of
the homeostat. It undertakes action
to reduce discrepancy relative to a
prior held belief, fixed in this case
about what temperatures are expected
preferred. The dialectic of the first
two PS from livestream number 37. This
is an expectation and a preference
because expectations having to do with
survival are as good as inference for
survival over evolutionary time.
Okay, this is going to be contrasted
with figure three
B, which is the alo stat. We see
the same stack of x one
Y one, light Bleu, dark Bleu, red,
except there is now a second column next
to it and there's some cross
connectivity. So again, the x's are
going to be beliefs about so prior's on
and then these are observations. And so
they're saying this generative model
extends the homeostat by including a
second set of exteroception variables
that correspond to light intensity y,
two observations of light, and beliefs
about sunrise. So like beliefs about the
generative process. So generative model
of the generative process.
Furthermore, the model includes a
predictive relationship between sunrise
x two and body temperature y.
So again, I wish we could label every
edge because the edges are meaning
different things even at different
times. Like this is a predictive
relationship. So it's an anticipatory
one, but then the one about light
intensity and the belief about sunrise,
there would be ways to make that an
anticipatory or an instantaneous
relationship. But the result of this
sketched architectures is that inferring
a sunrise, which will only happen with
high posterior confidence if the visual
observations are consistent. So low
prediction error inferring a sunrise,
not quote, seeing a sunrise. That is
not what is happening in the model
inferring a sunrise and finding that
visual observations are compatible with
it can trigger the autonomic response.
The behavior you of thermal regulation
in an anticipatory manner, that is
before sunlight actually increases body
temperature. Well, how would the
parameter be set that way? Because if
that were adaptive, then other parameter
accommodations have been weeded out
already by evolution. So that is
where we tuck the thread back into the
ball of yarn, which is the parameter
communication that are nonadaptive die,
they dissipate, they fail to exist,
they're not going to be measured as
things in the culture empirically,
however you Kant to take it. So how does
it work? It's the same as it was 50
years ago, which is it has to do with
survival of the persistent. Stephen.
And these graphs,
what they are used for as well as they
do show beliefs field to the
observation space. That the space
available around the observation.
Whatever the sensorium that is
available, that's what gives the beliefs
its scope. And then the
expectations are tied
in here more clearly to action. So the
errors, the errors are what's
important. The actual dynamic
that's driving action to change
something is coming out of the
prediction area. Errors that's feeding
into action. I think that's quite
important because this is like the proto
animal, this is like the proto kind of
piece here that ties into a lot
of how we think about knowledge and
meaning. And I'm not saying that I'm
just extrapolating a lot, but I think it
does show how beliefs are tied to
the type of sensors that
is being used to shape the conversation
space. I think that's quite useful.
Yeah. And these are just good.
I just want to get both you guys
opinions about that orange bar bell at
the bottom of the diagram, because
talking identity, but we're also still
talking about dependency, we're talking
about duplication, we're talking
about anticipation. So that's a lot of
stuff packed in one orange barbell.
What do you think? Yeah,
I'm going back to the full caption.
The red circles represent the expected
values of X. So if we're
interpreting these as the posteriors on
X, because the expectations, the errors
are the top Bleu ones, so it wouldn't
have to be the red circles and
they don't mention the word orange.
Note it's there and
it's identity. Note the lateral
modulatory connections in the Allostasis
network. See 24 for details. And 24 is
the graphical brain with frist and par
and de. Bruce so,
yeah, again, this is just a sketch
module. They're not using it to fit any
data or even simulate any data.
And it does relate to what Steven said
about the Intersensory or the intermodal
inference, which is one could imagine a
cognitive model where if
there's noises that are associated with
sunrise, then beliefs about sunrise can
be a variable with edges coming from
different sensory modalities. So it
gives us a exploration of the organs
of sense and interface
cognitive modeling. Stephen yeah,
it gives a sense of when would something
be important to act upon. So there's
many, many things that I could believe
I'm seeing or being perceived in terms
of this is sunrise, or this
is the type of light coming in, this is
the nature of the light, this is where
the light is coming from. There's all
sorts of stuff. The stuff that's really
filtering down is what
is important and
this is where the affordance is coming,
what affords me to make some action.
If it was expanding out, there can be
lots of things I noticed. Like I might
notice that there's a line there and I
may notice and believe it's orange, but
I may not act upon it until I take my
attention to it and think it's useful as
there's many things going on on the
page. So when we're we have beliefs,
but then there's what's being acted upon
out of all of that to then create
some sort of change. So I think that is
also quite useful in this architecture.
Can I add to this because I think really
important. So we're talking about
in the context of the sun coming up,
but let's see whether it still is
true. And I think it is just to prove a
point whether that orange barbell still
makes sense. If we're talking about
Daniel anticipating 61 year old Daniel
and Stephen anticipating 61 year old
Steven, and Dean anticipating 61 year
old Dean, now I'm much closer to 61 than
the two of you, but do I need the Monte
Carlo? Do I need the play out to be able
to make that anticipation? As long as I
have the identity and the parallelism
and the backwards and forwards looking
dependency that we see between X one and
X two and Y one and Y two, that's what I
think makes this a very interesting way
of being able to sort of build on the
previous homeostatic examples.
Klaas. Stephan yeah, I think also this
speaks to traditionally we
think about the meaning, what does this
mean, what's all the meaning out there?
As you mentioned, all the data, the
stuff that it could mean to relate all
these variables. But ultimately,
and the bit that is actually what active
inference gives us is that barbell is
where the learning comes in. It's like
the way to know how being
61 is for you Dean, is for you to
image what it would be like to
make choices and to act in the world as
a 61 year old Dean. Not necessarily to
go out and look at all the data,
so to speak, all the beliefs and the
things we think about the world, but to
actually bring that in. And of course
you've got a better chance to do that
because you're closer to being that kind
of Dean. So I think that's quite
interesting. That barbed at the bottom
in terms of pairing together the
kind of beliefs about what actions and
prediction Brea are available and it's
more into that meaningful action,
meaningfulness realm, rather than what
does it mean? What's the data Jelle?
We might get there. And I'm not pushing
back on what you're saying, Stephen, we
might get there. But I think for now,
what we're saying is that in order to
get there, we have to have more than a
single stack of dependencies.
We have to have a double stack in
order to be able to extend the
homeostatic nature of
how we've evolved to where we are.
Again, I'm not pushing back on you. I'm
just saying I don't want to jump that
firing pistol just yet because I think
that orange barbell is going to turn
into a green arrow and then all hell's
going to break loose anyway, so we
should carry on. I don't want to take
Stephen stuff away, but I think I want
to park it because we're going to go
somewhere in a minute. I'm hesitant
to ascribe too much specificity
to something that wasn't labeled in the
caption. Doesn't have a clear labeling
in the figure either. But I think it is
already demonstrated that using
graphical framework and partitionings
like we have in active inference, we can
start to approach some of these
questions like how would different kinds
of variables be connected? How does that
relate to future inference on action
counterfactuals, etc. Okay, so these
sections 4567 were
just laying out the relationship between
an evolutionary or a physiological
function like homeostasis allostasis or
simple behavioral control models of
things that are core evolutionary
features and function, connecting them
to the kinds of internal representation,
which are like a little bit of a hybrid
of a Bayesian graph and a
factor graph because there's some kind
of computations being implied here,
whereas in a Bayesian graph, the edges
only reflect statistical dependencies,
whereas we're bringing in a little bit
more of like a nuanced type relationship
that one could imagine could be
unpacked. A bit more were to be
specified. But it's just to show how
different graphical models relate
to different brain architectures
underpinnings whether you think this is
the actual architectures or whether it's
just an instrumental architecture like a
model structure on a given phenomena.
How do model architectures relate to
evolutionary functions? Where is
evolutionary time in this model? We
started out by asking like, how do
cognitive phenotypes arise specifically
over evolutionary but also over
developmental time? And that's where we
get to one of the main pieces and
contributions of the paper, which is
figure four, the five main dimensions
of elaboration of generative model
models introduced in this paper. So
there are other kinds of Chang Kim
ways that this structure could evolve,
but they're going to focus on these
five. There's starting with the
homeostat. Does it leave to be our
starting point? Maybe not. Starting with
the homeostat, there's the I operation,
which is identity unchanged. There is
I plus I, which is just a parallel
isolated duplication that's like from
one photoreceptor to going to two
photoreceptors, so to speak. There's the
alastat, which is a implication as well
as a cross linking. So these are just
sketches. One could also probably write
that one as like a duplication followed
by a linking and there's no like change
in linking, for example here. So this is
like a few of a taxonomy of operations.
There's increases in temporal depth
within a level of the hierarchy. So
looking one more unit further in time
at a given time scale and then there's
hierarchical nesting with a h. And the
figure is shown like this because these
are like the things that can happen to
the homeostat and then they can have a
second round and so on and so on.
There's so many other ones that could
happen. Like where is reduction,
where's loss, where's deduplication,
where's the uncoupling of the
allostasis? Reduction of temporal depth,
reduction of hierarchy. So there's a
broad space. But one of the main
contributions of this paper is to
connect functionally oriented graphical
models of homeostatic and physiological
function to the operations
that result in the elaboration of
simpler model architectures into
different architectures. Steen, this is
an interesting part. I know Steven wants
to say something to but really quickly,
there's no plus minus multiply and
divide. There's an operation,
but there's no symbolism for that.
And again, that keeps it
safe on a statistical level. I think
that's a nice tell there.
Again, for somebody who's just sort of
looking at this for the first time,
pointing that out, it's not there and
because it's not present, that tells us
something to your point about maybe how
do we get implication?
Yes, well, I plus I it
is like it's a suggestive use
of the addition operator, but we're not
adding these just like integers. So yes,
they're kind of like categorical
operations that constitute
this evolution algebra. Okay. Steven,
anything on figure four? Yeah, I was
just saying that I was saying they've
set a paradigm from the homeostat
and they've taken that through and
they've shown that plausibly can carry
through to cognition. And then like you
say, there can be other ways. But what
they've now given is they've given some
legs. Another way to think of the legs
that can be attached to that paradigm
because this modern approach, while they
could have chosen a lot of others by
taking it, there are certain things that
you're hard baked into that early stage
choicemaking which then makes other
paradigms wouldn't fit with it. Right?
Even if you go instrumental realist,
your instrumental models, your realist
models don't make sense unless you with
this, unless you take in some of the
paradigms of this structuring creates.
Yeah, agreed. Thanks. So just maybe
think like is this functional model
realism? Like the function of the model
is what is being tracked through time
and so there's many other
alterations that could occur and then
there's even more granular like
parametric changes or changes in
connectivity or edge types. And then I
think as you
said, Dean, when all hell breaks loose.
What's interesting here, let's look at
the alo stat in a little bit closer
detail. Okay? So previously we looked at
the alistat and we were like, okay,
there's an orange bar. Now the
Alastat has a free bar.
It's Green Arrow and it's a
unidirectional one. This one a
dependency.
The Alo stat has
the green bar. Okay, well, those are my
bad eyes because I saw the little arrow
from the Bleu actually turning. I didn't
actually see that there was two circles.
Thank you. There's my 60 year old eyes
for you. Yeah.
Okay, cool. And so
each of these are in quite a different
domain or at least like a different
aspect of cognition. And these are
the transitions that it can engage in.
So, like, duplication retains the exact
same function, but it's a very important
step. And that's a little bit what
explored in the zero with genetic
duplications, like on the left side here
at the screen, having a region
of the genome duplicate. Yes, one of
the duplicate copies can just
degenerate. That may be like opening
up space or creating motifs for other
kinds of later evolutionary steps. So
even this is not like a failure, it's
just a change. There's neo
functionalization, where then those two
models can start to subspecify. Like if
you only have one photoreceptor, it has
to be doing what it's doing. But
duplicating, it then allows one
to focus on a different wavelength than
the other, for example. And then there's
sub functionalization, which is where
initially a composite function, a B
becomes two, like enzymes
start to subspecialize on one of the two
functions of the ancestral. So it's kind
of like a role duplication. So
duplication is an important event.
Then there's the Alo stat and multiple
things happen with A. But we're seeing
it as there is a implication occurring
and there's also cross linking occurring
between beliefs in one modality or
beliefs about one type of thing
influencing observations or
about another kind of thing, as well
as this lateral modulatory, green orange
bar.
And then we have two kinds of expansions
into temporal depth, a sort of local
expansion with the T operation just
pushing the model one step deeper. And
then the H hierarchical nesting
operation. Which brings it to another
timescale analysis. Dean and this is
where I really struggled. And that is
when you were at Alastat, it wasn't just
comparative. I felt like you had to
build in time, especially if we're
talking about identity. But then it was
like, no, we're just going to leave a
comparative and then we're going to
introduce the wedding of this. I mean,
I understand why they're doing that to
try to make it tractable, but I don't
know how they can say it can be
comparative learning. I know active
inference between A and B right now,
but not sort of address the fact that in
order to differentiate into A and B,
some amount of time had to had to
be applied to that split.
I was saying you have to go back in time
in order to just be able to do a
comparison. So it's temporal only going
forward in time. I don't mean all hell
broke loose, but I mean, I did ask this
question. You're right. Like here
there's the triggering in an
anticipatory manner. And so in one view,
it's like, but this is a single time
step model, so how could that occur?
Because it doesn't have a temporal
depth. On the other hand,
again, like kind of those two senses of
representation in the structural sense,
if the model is a single time step
model, it kant have a representation
through deep time ergo, it cannot be
anticipatory function. The other side of
the coin would be if it's enough at this
time step, such that beliefs about
sunrise, trigger and response, the model
can be functionally anticipatory without
a temporal depth representation. Which
is why the representation discussion was
very important leading up to this one,
because we're all over those eight
quadrants here, because in
evolution and this is something that
like cognitive psych people talk about
is like our
cognition being shaped towards
effective, which is to say productive
reproductive success,
not towards like, ultimate truth
discovery. And so should we be too
surprised that our interpretation,
which has had a certain objective
function, is then susceptible to
being convinced about things that are
not true? I don't socialize
with those people. So I don't know. I
just knew that when I was looking at it,
I was thinking in real practical terms,
what is built into this in order for it
to still make sense? And that wasn't
necessarily parsed out in the diagram.
You kind of had to fill that in through
your own interpretation of what was
going on. So thus back to discrepancy.
That discrepancy thing is going to come
up again and again, and I'm really glad
that they inserted it at the beginning.
Klaas. E. Stephan think it's useful
here to hear this temporal depth and
hierarchical depth being sort of
spelled out, because I think it's
sometimes it's a little confusing in
other papers quite where it fits. So
temporal depth and this, again, might be
where some of this ontology work can be
useful, just to see if that can be kind
of consistent. But if temporal depth is,
you've got variables for past, present
and future states, but they're operating
maybe within the same kind of dynamics.
And then if you've got different
temporal rates operating
simultaneously, then you get that
hierarchical depth. And I thought in the
past, I sometimes thought temporal depth
would have covered that more
hierarchical depth. So this
is interesting to think about whether
this might be actually the way that
differentiation is best made.
Differentiation is probably best made
with reference to a specific model. And
this gives us the design language and
the grammar and the motifs. So if we
want to predict 100 years in the future,
should we have a decade model
with ten year models? That's a
times depth of ten decades and then a
nested model with a depth of ten years
or so. We have a one layer model with
100. They're very different
and it's not to say that one is like
more accurate or less and depending on
how the exact situation is set up,
maybe the computational requirements of
one or higher or different than the
other. But that's the discussion to
have. Do we want to have a B transition
matrix? Let's look at a nested model
with temporal depth. So here we
have on the top level of the model s
state two, this is temporal
depth happening at the upper level of
the model, three discrete time points in
an upper level that is temporal
depth, there's also nesting
within each time
step. There's a cognitive rollout on
three time steps. This is one type of
nested model but there's other nestings
that can exist. So here we see a depth
of two and then at each level
of the nesting there's three temporal
depth but they're
totally different in architectures and
in function. So it is the interesting
discussion, especially when
we have to do multiscale prediction like
Fermi estimation. So if the prediction
is within one time scale there
isn't necessarily a need to least but
once we get into larger time scales or
where there's emergence over multiple
timescales, it makes sense to have a
nesting model. Like if we wanted to
predict someone's activity over the next
seven DAGs, it might make sense to have
a day model with a nested model inside
of that, because then within each day
there could be parameter setting versus
just trying to fit one time series and
find the parameters that make that one
time series oscillate in a circadian
way. Instead we just need a day model
with a very specific kind of simple
transition and then a transition at a
nested level with a depth that is
measured at the hourly or the minute
time scale rather than the days. And
that becomes especially important when
doing familybased model fitting like
variational inference. So we're not just
like getting all the data points and
fitting a spline through them, but we
actually need to have appropriate model
structure otherwise free energy
minimization will drive right off the
cliff just like we talked about with
axles bacterium. So if we want to do
free energy minimization and model
selection on model structures,
we can find the best model relatively
easily given the families that we've
specified. But there's no guarantees
once we step outside of that spotlight
that we're even in the right category
structurally. And so that's why humans
having these design motifs in mind and
many many many more helps us not get
into what seems to be a global
optimization based upon free energy
minimization but actually is a very
relatively local optimization based upon
unimaginative model structured learning.
Steven yeah, thanks, that's really
helpful. Also ties Hinton something I've
been really thinking about in terms of.
The modeling itself is these scales,
these steps. You know, you're talking
about the multi year decades when we're
modeling, it's like, what do we have
access to? So we tend to ascribe that in
terms of what can we externalize, what
can we use to put something into a model
if it's instrumental? And then of
course, there's a question of, well,
what is the realist perspective on that
and what is there that's within our
conscious awareness of being in the
world, something that can be reported as
an event, a story, and what timescales
are present there? When you get into 100
years, it's beyond that. So then you're
saying, okay, what are you going to
extrapolate? What sort of temporal
structure? But on the other scale, if
I'm asking what do I think I expect you
to do next, or Dean to do next? And it
might seem intuitive, I can have a whole
series of temporal and nested
scales going on which is not even
available to me in a cognitive
conscious way. I might have a sense of a
feel for what I think is going on, but a
lot of my predictive processing will be
happening at rates unavailable to my
conscious awareness. So that also ties
in, I suppose. I'm not saying it's an
answer, sort of adds to the challenge,
I suppose, but it is the challenge of
how much ends up being what we can get a
measure on to put into our model as much
as what it is. And that's the same
challenge in a way that comes even from
the realist perspective at some level as
an organism. What is it that I even can
access in some realistic way? Not saying
we can model it or know that could be
put into something like this. So I think
you're going to say something.
So the paper is talking about how do we
use certain math to be able
to understand maybe the evolution of
cognition, right? That's essentially
what the paper is trying to point us in
that direction. So again, in order to
make this accessible, in order to sort
of lower the barrier for people who
actually want to have this make sense
because they don't necessarily spend
sums and sums of hours on trying to
figure this stuff out, like the authors
or maybe even us. I Kant to point
out something that I think is obvious to
us, but maybe not so obvious to people
who are looking at this and going, I
have no idea what they're saying. I
think, first of all is that there's a
chronology which we keep going back to,
not just at the temporal depth level,
so that's relativity math. There's brain
evolution aspect of this, so that's
algebraic math and there's a dependency,
so there's a statistical math. Do we
have to be polymath in order to be able
to feel our way through this? And I'm
going to go back to what I said at the
end of the 37,
Karl Friston said, you don't have to be
polymath, but you better be at least
somewhat comfortable feeling comfortable
with the math, because there's no one
math that's going to get you here. It's
a blending of all of them, and then it's
how you feel about that. That's probably
going to be the thing that lowers the
impediment to really being able to use
this now in real practical terms going
forward. So what's the next evolutionary
step? Right. It's how you're able to
turn this into something. So I
think that's one of the great gifts of
this paper. If you're not afraid of
being, if you don't consider, if you
don't Kant to identify now or you don't
duplicate now, or you don't allostasis
now as a polymath, maybe that's
something we owe people
that want to get into this.
Maybe the British pronunciation of maths
helps reflect that. There's already a
plurality of maths. And Kirby Earner,
coming more from the cybernetics side,
talks a lot about this, actually. Like
how the discourse around math as
universal language makes it sound like
math is a singular language, when
actually math is a pluriverse. And so
maths reflects that a little better.
It's not like these are just sort of
slopes on one mountain and that's Mount
Math, and it's so high and only a few
people get to the top and scale every
side. This is just like we're using
maths. Yes. Of all different klaas.
Stephan. You see a lot
of this in the papers that are published
active inference lab. There's often a
team of people, a group of people,
where maybe one member has that higher
level understanding the math. But the
other question is to understand what
would it mean to make an observation
that could be a very good the
mathematician may not be the one. Like
some of the work with Ryan Smith's work
on the gut, you know, it was like,
well, they're going to do gut inference.
Well, how do you get some tractable
source on what's the gut doing? So they
created some electrode. I'm not quite
sure Hohwy they did it, but they had
some way of getting sensory information,
effectively sensory information, or
effectively some sort of information to
put into their model. And so knowing how
action and observations can
flow in and the implications of that, I
think, is also kind of a big part
of this. Right. And in some
cases it may be a trivial part because
it's fairly obvious. In other parts,
that may be the biggest barrier,
and then that may be the biggest barrier
as well, often in organisms. Right.
How do you even access plausibly, the
approximation science, which isn't so
approximately it's just chaos that it's
tractable. Yeah. The rate limiting step
or impact and improvement in
the real world is unlikely to be any
single individual's conceptualization of
math on a team if
it's structured appropriately. And for
those pushing the frontiers of math.
Their understanding of math is quite
literally a rate living step for them.
Or maybe it might be something very
mundane like time availability. But when
it comes to thinking about real model
based science and translational
implication of active inference,
I think that we're working towards new
ways of combining skills and having
shared knowledge resources that help
make that make sense and using shared
language and ontologies narratives,
formal documents, tools on Ft because
we're doing it on teams and we're
online. Let's just in the last 2030
minutes go through the final pieces of
the paper so that this dot one will have
been like a first sweep,
initial pheromone deposition, and then
we can return and take some cul de sacs,
etc. So, action nine,
explore a little bit how the duplication
operation allows for
multiple behaviors to arise and that's
sort of by analogy to the genomic
duplications and specializations and all
those different routes that can occur
here. They connected duplication a
little bit more directly to the factor
graph models.
In. The sense that duplicated motifs
have dynamics that are conserved over
different sensory motor domains. So
let's just say that we just had a visual
model, it was a column of visual and
then we duplicated it. So now we have
two photoreceptors with parallel columns
and now the photoreceptor in the second
one changes into a chemo receptor
because instead of expressing Rhodopsin
protein, it's expressing an olfactory
receptor protein. There can be
a conversation of the dynamics of
inference even when the observation
has changed. But it was a slot for
observation. And so we went from having
like monocular vision to binocular
vision to monocular vision and
olfactory perception. But you can't get
there in one jump to just like duplicate
and transpose. It's not likely to happen
in brain evolution context. And we can
see the structure of these hierarchical
model as equivalent to being
factorized probability distributions,
which is to say that the sparse
connectivity of variables means that we
can make parts of the model that can be
like fine tuned independently in a way
that can be fit very attractively.
That's the factor graph, that's
factorized Bayesian inference. And we've
talked about that in other places. But
just here all we need to say is
duplication enables like A control
C control V copy paste and then let's
edit the other version. But that can now
happen with evolution features and
functions. Dean, real quick, your hand
gestures in this section point to the
orthogonal mesh beginning and
then .2 I'd like to pull that apart a
little bit, but let's carry on. But
that's what I took away from this. The
mesh began and in the beginning there
was a mesh begins. We'll return
to that for dot two.
Okay, section ten talks
about temporal depth. It's about
time and about the encoding of
generative models with temporal depth
and the way that that supports
prospective inference, anticipation or
retrospective inference, which is like
memory. So here's what the operator
looks like. We have X sub tau x at a
time point, and then now there's X tau
plus one the next time point, or t
plus one could be now, and then t
could be the last moment.
So memory. And I
still see figure four.
Slide 29. Okay.
Yeah. So the structure of anticipation
and of memory are very similar. It just
depends whether one has the stream of
observations happening on the left side
and a prospection, or the stream of
observations are on the right side and
in which case it's retrospection.
Stephen yeah, I mean, it sort of ties
in. They talk about what the police do
is very hard for someone to lie
backwards. So you always get them to
tell their story backwards because it's
very hard for them to do that because
they say if we're creating things
retrospectively but playing them
forward, so to speak, it would kind of
tie them out.
I want to emancipate that.
I looked up police in the paper. I see
policies.
Is that policies?
It's a great opportunity for my favorite
joke, but I won't thank you.
This action talks about temporal depth.
Okay. From whence temporal
depth. Various researchers have
speculated that a major driving force
for the development of deep temporal
models was foraging. And there's a lot
of interesting empirical and conceptual
reasons to think about foraging in terms
of temporal and spatial depth of model.
And that's true in the Vertebrates,
where they're discussing mainly, like,
hippocampus and entorhinal system and in
the invertebrates that don't have a
hippocampusentorhinyl system. But it's
one reason why comparative neuroscience
is so important, because it prevents us
from getting fixed on specific
anatomical realizations of given
functional attributes of evolutionary
systems. Like, if the story of memory
is just about some brain region in
humans, it may be a useful model.
It's not even to say that it's
inaccurate. It's not even to say that
it's a partial model. It just is a model
of that. Whereas if we want to
understand a given cognitive function in
a broader context, we leave to pull back
somewhere a little bit beyond or in
complement to the anatomy, because we
need the empirical anatomy to have
anything specific to be talking about.
But it isn't just the case that
vertebrate anatomy is the way to do
active inference. Steven I think this is
really helpful because it shows that the
traps you were just mentioning there
that people we fall into is like humans
have the frontal cortex. It's all about
this new what's, the new parts of the
brain that are there. But we don't say
that with a Formula One car. We say,
well, it's just got a primitive engine
thing in there, and the rest of it's
evolved. It's like, well, that's itself
different. And the same with the mark
Ines conversation.
The evolution of what's often dismissed
as the primitive parts of the brain.
They themselves can have been more
sophisticated, though they're doing more
things, but they maybe
help to be doing more than they were,
as opposed to there's something else
that is doing all the heavy lifting,
which I think is certainly a common
misconception, I think, in psychology
anyway. Dean, can I read quickly
from the paper? Sure. The evolution of
temporarily deep models from simpler
models could be realized during
evolution via the progressive keyword
here correlation of an initially
differentiate model. So a relative
sense of invariance, ie. A model that
does not distinguish present from past
and future into a model that features
separate latent states for the past,
present and future. This is the part I
loved. A key drive for this
factorization or correlation
may have been the observation and
progressive internalization of the
sensor motor sequences sequentially that
the animal creates and experiences while
acting. While acting. In other words,
the self modeling of one's own
sequential behavior patterns. See 53 for
a computational example. I didn't open
up 53. But again, if we want to talk
about the polymath piece of this and the
fact that our hex cells have to do some
parcellization, it's right there in
terms of sort of the next layer
on top of this as we move up through
that evolutionary cycle. Yeah.
53 is Stoinove et al.
The hippocampal formation as a
hierarchical generative models
supporting generative replay and
continual learning? There's a ton that
could be said about that from like a
computational and a neuroanatomical
perspective. The internalization
of the sensory motor sequences relates
to the sensory motor detachment that we
talked about in the representation
paper. So if some motor region
in the brain, if it's like a marionette
and the fingers and then the motor plant
so that motor region has to be coupled
to the activity of that motor region,
like either in a one directional way or
maybe even in a bi directional way,
let's just say. So that system as it
thinks, so it does, and vice versa, it
cannot engage in counterfactuals because
any direction that the neural system
turns, the motor system is just simply
doing that. So it is not able to
engage over evolution time in adaptive
action. The ones that do no longer
persist. It's always
what ties it back to reality and to the
finite amount of entities on the finite
spaceship Earth. Like Darwin's famous
calculation, like if the number of
elephants slowly reproducing, they'll
cover the Earth unless their population
levels are kept in check. And so once
there's sensory motor detachment, so
there's some brain region, either a
motor region or some supplemental area,
some ancillary area that's able to
intervene in that process or somehow
play a role that's detached from the
motor activity. Now, there can be like a
motor planning occurring that
opens up the affordance of temporal
depth or of counterfactuals all these
other cognition functions arising via
the sensory motor detachment. And so
foraging is an awesome place to look at
that for a lot of reasons in
different life forms and computational
foraging and so like, just a few of the
notes were like what are the real
cognitive demands of foraging for
different creatures? And what about
internal foraging, like mental foraging?
And these papers are very good.
Foraging in mind and foraging in
semantic fields, both very useful,
because they have to do with the way
that they have some nice maths too,
but they have to do with how
actions that are spatial can have
conserved. Dynamics structurally. Just
like we explore here to mental actions
and then we see them come together,
like with a memory palace or something
like that. So foraging is cool.
It's good to study eleven endowed
generative models with hierarchical
depth of ours. Multiscale inference. We
kind of addressed that earlier with the
decades and years. Nested temporal
modeling is not the same as just deep
temporal modeling.
Another way to look at that is like how
many operations you would need to get to
a hundred years. Well, if you're going
to do only temporal depth, it's going to
take plus 100 or 99 time steps versus if
it's one nesting and then
ten on the higher order than ten on the
lower order. It was 21 operations. And
so then there's shorter sequence
of events to achieve a higher affordance
model, assuming that they're
appropriate.
Section twelve? Yeah, go ahead. Just one
thing just on that model and it's also
interesting thinking about how we think
of time because indigenous approaches
tends to be Jelle as a cyclical time,
right? So things in the future will be a
repeat of the cycle so the times
of thought of in a cyclic motion of the
sort of passing of the day, passing of
the and of course we have
this assumptions of time stretching out.
So is it that we will over
time, what will things be like in
four generations?
And if my world and my biology follows
certain cyclical patterns and it's
fairly stable, maybe that's quite a good
way to think about,
say, Kant the tree now to help the
people in 150 years. So it
sort of comes back to the different ways
to construct how we think
about time.
Cool. So Twelve looks into
a phylogenetic tree of the evolution of
generative models so what
is a phylogenetic tree and what's the
relationship between active inference,
FEP and evolution? Well, we'll have more
to share in the coming papers, as always
but how do they address it specifically
here in figure five they
map on we'll root the tree so
technically, as shown right here, it's
an unrooted tree. There is an
implication routing here but it's a very
interesting feature of phylogenetics
that few outside of the field know about
that computationally the tree is often
inferred in an unrooted fashion like by
clustering the ones that are close and
finding the relationships, et cetera.
However, that is leaving an
ambiguity as to where the root of the
tree is. So like for example, if this is
the overall connectivity based
upon the phylogenetic inference, this is
what the tree topology has been inferred
to look like and somebody might say,
well, it looks like this one, the red
one and then the green one below it.
They are, they're clearly very closely
related but actually if the root comes
in here then that's
not necessarily the case. So the rooting
of a phylogenetic tree is very important
and a tree that's rooted inappropriately
or has an inappropriate group selection
is just it's worse than illegible
because it's highly legible and it can
have a high statistical confidence but
it can have an absolutely nonbiological
topology. But assuming that they meant
the tree to be rooted here,
here the branches are where there's
going to be different operators
occurring encoding the eye identity,
unchanging one and then the
edges reflect like bifurcations
expectation events. So here there's an
ancestral homeostat and then the lineage
leading to orange did not go undergo any
changes that were nonconservative on the
branch leading to these sister species.
There was a duplication and then it
stayed the same and stayed the same and
then the purple node is going to have
two duplicated homeostas and so they're
just overlying evolutionary algebra the
steps that they gave on to the topology
of speciation. And so that
as they discuss opens
up a way to think from this sort of
graphical functional perspective which
is compatible with active to think about
how, for example, from the species today
we could infer some of the schema of the
early vertebrate brain with the early
primate brain or push it back further.
What about the common ancestors of the
vertebrates and the invertebrates and
all these other questions but that's
kind of what they lay out here. These
are familiar models to evolutionary
biologists like phylogenetic
ancestral state reconstructions of
phenotype which are often even done in a
Bayesian way. Like there's an algorithm
beast Bayesian estimation of ancestral
states. This is also a Bayesian
model that allows us to do
reconstruction of ancestral states but
it's in a very different way than it's
been approached outside of the active
world. But that's figure five and
that's where we see the evolutionary
algebra, the design patterns or the
pattern language for structural changes
in generative models super imposed on
species relatedness in a phylogenic
tree.
Any thoughts on five? I tried to convert
this and reapply it to my picking
of teams in the March Madness table and
I wasn't able to take philosophenetic
trees and convert them into winning
thousands of dollars on betting on
college basketball. So despite my best
efforts, it's kind of contained for
what it represents dot. Two foreshadow
too hard, but I think live stream number
39 and 40 might constitute March
Madness. And then also here's
another for those who watch.
Okay, here now we have a little bit of a
March Madness bracket going, don't we?
Here's bracketology. That is so
fantastic. So here we go.
Yeah, now here the root
could have been here and then here's
like two big species clades, like two
like this is like vertebrates and
invertebrates and then there's some
rooted clade. Wow. So that's
like why it's important to root the tree
because here it looks like all of these
are a sister to each other at the
exclusion of this one. But then if we
were to have rooted that tree like here,
then actually this is a small sister out
group to all of these and so
the rooting and the contextualizing is
really important. It's super interesting
because it seems like you put in so much
data into these phylogenetic models and
it seems like literally how could this
not converge on a super obvious answer?
I mean, isn't it clear how these answer
related to each other phylogenetically?
But then there's a little bit of nuance
that enters the picture. Steven.
Yeah, I was curious that the allostasis
can recombine with the homeostatic
to give a base level temporal.
It doesn't deflate back to just staying
allostasis I suppose they would be they
just don't show that it
did that. I suppose you just wouldn't
talk about it when it
goes to a and then it goes AI goes to
HT so th yeah,
so we have a. Homeostat here we have two
homeostats, two homeostats and now here
we have one homeostat and one allostasis
in this Bleu node.
But they're just kind of giving general
examples like it would have been cool to
see this is where we're talking about
mammals and here's non mammal
vertebrates. Like here is a specific
brain region and also that is in this
Chakraborte and Jarvis 2015 paper.
This paper gets more
into the nuances of neuroanatomy and
neurogenetics and how like implication
in brain regions
can be underpinned by developmental
neurogenetic changes. And they do link
that a little bit more closely, like to
studying the bird brain and the song and
motor system in parrots,
which is also cool because Birdsong has
been studied with active. So there could
be a nice building upon this
work and connecting it to some of the
structure fitting in figure five.
So it COVID almost be like you got parts
of the brain which are more allostasis
orientated or homeostatic orientated and
that so in a way by the structuring of
that gives some sort of differentiate in
terms of how information and control
would be carried out. Yeah,
totally extending temporal depth within
a model. It's like a brain region
getting a little bigger, let's just say
not that size is correlated with
function in that specific way but then
duplicating brain regions is like
duplicating laterally or nesting of
brain regions. It's hierarchical. Think
about how the eyes developed the insect
eye, it has a relatively simple module
but then insect eyes can change in size
over evolutionary time very radically
from like taking up half of the head to
being just one photoreceptor or even
being lost because they're existing
in more of a duplicable motif.
Whereas the binocular eye
system that mammals have, it's not as
amenable to like just doubling into four
eyes or splitting into two in
the middles or something like that,
whereas the insect compound eye has some
of those evolutionary affordances. So
then understanding like parameter change
within a model and then structure
learning on populations of models and
what are the mutational adjacencies.
There are so many awesome areas and it's
like truly just beginning for
evolutionary bio active states. Yeah,
it was really helpful. Having someone
like yourself who's got that background
to go through. That is quite helpful
because it's a little
bit intimidating, actually, at first
sight seeing this for me,
I see the logic, what you're saying.
It's quite exciting actually seeing
that. Again, one of the things this
paper does is it's time threads together
which seem very distant almost
in traditional terms, like Jelle. I
don't like using the word kamikaze, but
it's a little bit like yeah, it's a
bit of overwhelming often. So I think
but of course, that's the beauty of
active is it has that unifying
potential. So thanks. Cool. Yeah,
thank you. I agree. There's some
labeling. This is rarely included unless
it's a time calibrated phylogenetic
tree, but like, we're looking at the
passage of time, but that's not even
always shown. Yes, Dean,
we'll have our final thought. Can you
just go back to that? Because I didn't
prompt you to put that up there. But I
really like that because at some point
we're going to have to in point to talk
about that sort of basal gating part of
this. And most things that are
organized as if then causality. But you
just said it. It's then if go or don't
go is very dependent on then before
we choose to go or don't go. Right. Go
or don't go is still held open until one
of the others decided. So another thank
you for that because the point too.
We should maybe talk a little bit about
that.
Cool. Yeah. There's so many ways to
think about like this garden of forking
paths, branching paths, how that
relates to parameter updating, Bayesian
belief updating and structured learning.
What about when the structure of a model
is a parameter in a nested model? So
then that sort of blurs the line. From
the bottom looking up, it looks like
structured learning, but then from the
top looking down, it looks like
parameter fitting. Right. And if only we
had like some mathematics to describe
that.
Okay, any final thoughts or what
are we excited about for the dot two to
next week? Well, my last thought
is yeah, I'm excited to keep this going
because I think it's got a lot of legs
to it. I think one thing that comes to
mind as well with all this progressively
increased temporal and hierarchical
depth, is maybe where some of the more
basic elements still have a really
useful part to play is what Mike Levin
said about when do we stop? So we got
all these ways where we can start to
okay, so we got all these ways that we
can think, how do we know when to stop
and to sit down? And maybe in the
ultimate ways when our tummy maybe
that's where the gut is so useful. Like
at the end of the day, the brain can go
running off and maybe the gut and the
heart needs to say, okay, sit down,
get some food. I'm going to get a
drink of honey now, but I'll bid you
feel well. Thank you for a great dark
time, but I'll hear your last thoughts
as well.
Dean, I hate having the
last word, so maybe you'll have a dory
you'll have it? And I just appreciate
Klaas. Stephan just said because I think
that that's a big part in this ability
to go from word back into the
phenomenological space. And I think
there are other brains that we know of
now that play a significant role in
that, not just the one that turns
everything Hinton, symbols.
Great. My last thought is there's no
better drink after a foraging trip than
honey.
Alright, thank you and talk to you
later.